[Music]
you ready yeah I'm ready Purge
Anarchy I was legitimately trying to fix
my
shirt I hate you really hard on that one
if you thought you weren't going to be
Purge for Purge Anarchy then you had
another thing coming I think I might
have pooped my pants a little bit and it
wasn't even scary oh Tara how I've
missed you we're back for another Purge
we're doing it man I'm ready we are back
because you guys liked us and we love
that so don't forget like this video
comment
subcribe ring the
bell ring the bell I'm really starting
to love it she didn't love it before but
now I'm getting her in it I got to shove
me in people's faces and eventually they
go I think I like it that's what she
said we are here for Redemption today
actually though because both Tara and I
said that we were Pro
Purge in the last video we are no longer
Pro Purge we're just Pro The Purge
franchise so we're back for the second
one and if you guys want to be back in
the biggest way possible go over to
patreon so you can have your full length
Reaction watch along where you sync up
with your own copy that's the super sexy
rejects only
baby wow and you get a dance which is
very cool if you guys were wondering if
Greg was off to the side eating a pen
right now he is but also Greg and John
cover shows over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included what are we purging today
negative energy oh oh oh people who
don't like Halloween stuff be gone get
out of here let's do
this so we don't know who's in this we
don't know if it's the same cast or
different cast I know nothing about this
one I mean I didn't know anything about
the first one but yeah what does anarchy
make you think like the first much more
Anarchy we could get with people just
going off on their own killing people
but can I tell you something yeah I plan
on being the Anarchy of this movie
[Laughter]
per okay oh
wow3 which is this year unemployment is
below 5% crime is virtually non-existent
while every year fewer and fewer people
live below the poverty line all thanks
to the perge The
Purge so this is the point in time where
I believed that people were good last
movie now we know they're not they're
not they're they're taking out lowincome
communities March 21st that's my
friend's birthday oo hey friend all
right we only have 2 hours 26 minutes
till the start of the purge all right
how are we prepping do we still got
security stuff or is everybody just like
giving up and they're like just blue
flowers all day long how is everything
Mr saan great as always good you get
home now Eva it's getting late stay safe
kind of recognize her it's my thing to
not know where people are from though
it'll soon be a war out there
prognosticator estim Sap's gone that's
it what is she waiting for why does this
[__] let us
go Eva oh you to ride home I'm fine
Carlos if he has to take me home I'd
accept that ride girl he's a dog I like
that dog I would walk the [__] out of
that
dog
you're disgusting it's true the dialogue
in this is pretty natural I can't even
lie you're really going to ask her
tonight I have to I can't afford his
medicine much longer this country it's
crazy Even in our the fake good world
yeah insulin is that what we think yeah
like what's the next most expensive Med
for a kid it's not going to be ater
all Frank gillo I like him yeah he's dop
he's a cute man too did you see him in
the oh no what's the show that was on
peacock
um the guy who thought that his life was
a movie and oh
um uh something P something whatever
Frank Grill in that he's a smoke
showell I love him from um
lights and his name is we don't know
he's also currently in the Fall of the
House of
Usher literally look like Taylor Swift
yeah why is he what are you looking at
going through
their nothing old stuff you about to
break up with her what's he doing our
regime was voted into office n years ago
and the first order of business with the
Epic of crime just straight up weird
heyart how you doing how you doing you
don't need for protection tonight Etta
look on a cheap Che or a blade to cut
your man throat whatever you need we
take any kind of payment I would buy a
blade I wonder if she already just for
dayto day also they don't need a
day-to-day one that's the whole thing
about The Purge take me up there with
you tonight get little protection you
know what I'm saying come on now you
want no thanks dieo I'm the man for the
job he plays a good drunk guy we no
longer worship at the alar of Christ
this guy Muhammad
Yahweh also famous
I saw his protest posters all around the
neighborhood he lives here Papa he's
just like us the purge is not about
containing crime to one night and
cleansing our souls but it's about one
thing money yeah we can't afford to
protect ourselves that's enough I can't
listen this crap he's as full of [__] as
they are he's not he is right he's
really not I'm going to take a long nap
and don't bother me going to try to
sleep through this godforsaken holiday
so weird calling it a holiday yeah I'm
sorry I'm so grumpy girls I hate this
night forgive me I love his voice so
last time we started with a rich family
this time we're not now we're the
opposite yeah I'll take care of my room
like boarded up he's old you're going to
let him take care I'd be like no man let
it I'll board up your room how did
things go with Mrs Crawley well did you
at least make a good argument did you
say everything that we practiced she
said nothing sorry baby maybe is just
trying to hold this family together I
said I want to tell your I I heard you
cuz as soon as you say it out loud to
another person then it's irreversible
maybe she's pregnant oh they're or
they're breaking up and that's why he
was looking at can you unlock the car
please it's unlocked no it's not
there okay perch God that scared
me uh aren't you a little bit early to
be puron yeah he can't do anything yet
he's just like marking them I don't know
all right taunting is a lot loud prior I
would not like
that oh that's
spooky I'd walk around with a barbed
wire jacket and barbed wire leggings yes
Roxy I said it bar
[Laughter]
guns it these guys would be like no I'm
not going to taunt her like barb wire
man we don't have a whole lot of time
before commencement Shane all right we
we'll be fine no problems you won't be
fine I see the sun setting sir also I'd
cover everything I have in like blue
flowers I'd want to be with Frank during
this time oh yeah he's got all the
weapons but blue flowers doesn't mean
they can't attack you it just means
you're Pro the holiday right but I still
would be like Oh I'm Pro also don't mess
with me you can't go out there you know
how dangerous it is go you need to
leave he's going to protect people seems
like it don't do this it won't make you
feel any better he lost somebody last
year go with you know husband and your
new family so that's his ex that clearly
something happened last year now he goes
out and he does this and helps but she
has a new family he seemes military the
way he's putting his guns together he's
got all his weapons he's like maybe he's
just a guy who knows guns I don't know
we must pick up arms this year we will
fight back I'm like yeah that does make
sense I guess if the poor just gained
had a lot of weapons right to defend
themselves then maybe they wouldn't be
taken out but I'm also like well how do
they afford to get those weapons to
defend
themselves what's happening here why
does he have a limo just say you changed
your mind not that we didn't come to a
joint
decision this is the EXA you think it's
a breakup I feel like it is right
exactly why we need to tell your sister
that we're separating
yeah tire blew out not going to make it
you said you were we all knew it pull
put something on the car I
think this is like the second meet cute
they were going to get separated and now
it's all going to go to [__] they're
going to be like we're going to get
married and have children now I would be
go home for like four days before The
Purge just to make you're not going
anywhere right yeah start
running so their grandfather left just
in case in a limo and that's why I'm
confused cuz why is she working at a
diner to get him medication and he can
get somebody sent him the limo that's
what when they said and he's like I'm in
a weird mood obviously he knew something
that was going
down oh
[__] wow h no thanks I jump over the
bridge I don't
know
wow
Purge oh God you're like a fortress you
can't Purge a purger you know a fortress
maybe if you had a
pillow News 13 Wishes anyone who is not
participating in this year's Purge a
safe evening oh ho ho I know her too Amy
paffrath oh wow good you good job on the
name this is your emergency broadcast
system announcing the commencement of
the annual Purge sanctioned by the US
government of class 4 and lower have
been authorized for use during The Purge
all other weapons are restricted what
are other weapons like bombs and
Emergency Medical Services will be
unavailable until tomorrow morning at 7
a.m. God maybe don't be terrifying hide
yeah like I wouldn't be in the middle of
street I don't understand how people
would go out to get to do an errand and
not take a weapon with them on the day
of the purge he might have something
with him I hope so nothing more than a
knife I don't think but
[Music]
what this is oh my
God they just hunt people this is
terrifying it's so smart of them to have
it start at sundown visually just like
that we were in the light for this whole
time it turns The Purge and we're in the
darkness waiting for the light yes
yeah the way that these movies are shot
you just feel effing petrified I
agree I mean especially the way they use
like the handheld and the and the angles
in it it's like it's
great but so why does that
why oh
my
goodness I was wondering if this dumb
guy in the truck would be like oh they
look like they're going to purge if they
look similar would he yeah I thought
maybe that yeah I don't know and why
would they if they know people do that
why would they just be out walking I
assumed everyone who has like a gun and
looks like they're purging doesn't mess
with other purgers is what I a
Callum okay well he didn't protect that
person this is ter I like everything now
that they're taking us out into the
world to show us I find it even scarier
yes so smart that the first one were
contained yeah so we did second one now
we're seeing it
[Music]
all
start looking for weapons break that
piece of wood I was just thinking that I
feel like somebody's in there trash can
oh yeah he's
smart get the other
one get the other one he said let's just
get out of here like what
okay [__] it's them we got to move we
got to move we got to
move this is the worst game of hide and
seek ever
ever
mom what what is it mom come
here oh my God I am not a fortress dear
stepen Kelly my greatest heartache is
seeing the two girls I love so much
struggling in this world I'll be a
martyr for a wealthy family tonight they
paid me for this
service $100,000 will be transferred
into your account how much
only 100,000 live a safe life oh my god
oh oh my God this
is I'm sick this makes me feel like in
my stomach like that my stomach try to
find I mean it's it's not going to be of
any use if these guys just plan on
cutting him up it's how the wealthy
Purge B baby they buy poor and sick
people and they take them into their
homes and they kill them where they're
safe we can do something about this I
don't know what but we can still do
something about stop he's gone that's
devastating it's really terrible there's
something so wrong with people that like
that's so believable yeah that I'm like
oh yeah it's all these richs I'm like
you already have everything you have
everything you need to survive in a
world and not struggle and yet you're
like on Purge night we would like to
kill people it's so mess stop it makes
me mad yeah I this movie like brings up
like what is
this who are they it looks like an army
I have no
idea oh maybe it's the drunk guy coming
to protect them who yeah oh going to
protect
you protect you from me oh no
what Frank Grilla what are you going to
do who are you here to help what he
hasn't helped any one yet oh my God
who don't you know that you got to be
polite to people in this Society Diego
don't come back here we have guns and we
will shoot you really I got a little
bonus got a little package deal e you
better prepare yourself tonight cuz
tonight it's mother our [__] it's my
night to Mother bur okay y'all need to
guide him towards the window and then
throw him out of
it where is Frank Grilla ah
oh no oh no this skateboarding
mother please leave
alone it
please what's that throw him out of the
window is that your father please please
get it girl oh gross oh my God I can't
get the gun somebody come on now you
want them to come and get it where you
oh good he's just going to get himself
killed I love it thank God
oh my God these are like professional
purgers like how many years have purging
cuz they look like freaking a SWAT team
oh no they're about to get purged
no now you're
screwed let's bring these two downstairs
Big Daddy we have two for your personal
Purge oh
[__]
that's it come on Frank oh I can't wait
for come on Frank come on Frank yes
Frank in the
Batmobile yeah hold on bulletproof
fireproof oh no that was like a stunt
person that was a great stunt Frank
what's your move here Frank just drive
just drive just drive yeah he can't he's
going to he's saying just drive like
don't don't help them but he can't help
it he has to help them Callie
F heard that so is they're all in like
protective gear they're going to be hard
to kill yeah but Frank gillow is no I
mean nobody's a match for him he's a pro
you're right he's probably like an army
dude maybe he's a seal like a
sniper please don't let him be a bad guy
is he going to get his carcked all oh no
by the kids they right behind us oh my
God they're going to steal his
car they're going to steal his car oh my
gosh [__] I knew it oh my God Frank's
then going to be out here is all of his
weapons in the I hate all of
it kill him let's go Frank yes yes
yes yes John Wicked that [__]
yeah
yes
oh yeah you psychopath yeah you maniac
but he's getting his car taken what's
going on out there we're safe we're safe
we're in here we're good oh no they're
going to get okay he's going to get back
in the car maybe has the
keys oh my
God please take them come
on okay God now he's got to take care of
four people my God what is he a little
full call he's a real daddy now he's a
purge Daddy I'll tell you that much
about sugar daddy he's a purge daddy
daddy I'm trying to look for my Pur
daddy Hey where's my Pur daddy I've be
lining up Purge Daddy's like two weeks
prior out of the
will I
will oh God don't
shoot get out of the oh I knew it this
little shut up hands up and shut your
mouth hands up and shut your mouth I
feel like that car bullets can't get
through
it ah ah here we have it over there too
Co please where do you want him to go
because it can come from any angle this
time this movie is just so much more
like the other one was intense for
different reasons but this is just
Anarchy this is
anarchy we didn't know where it would go
and now we do yeah
see wow him with the American flag on
his hat he's so effing he is like so
ready to purge every year what was that
Army doing in your building why were
they after you why would they after you
I know why are you in the streets our
car just broke down our car broke down
we don't want to hurt anybody are you
armed no no what were you doing outside
yeah saving your life I go out there to
help people I'm The Purge
Daddy I don't know why he talks like
that I made him talk like oh
no
oh this can't help anybody else sir
where are we going he doesn't have the
answers
God damn another car car what I thought
he had like an indestructible vehicle
maybe nowhere what' he say
nowhere yeah I think that's what he said
cuz he knows it's I bet you has enough
weapons to give all of them and then
they got to fight him I mean obviously
the tire is going to blow out when he's
getting shot at or engine yeah there
that's
what were we in this alley no he must
have put a neutral and pushed it I guess
you're on your own now huh wait what you
should have never gotten involved in Son
of my business okay but you did so it is
your business now no it's not it's
loaded take
it take it well at least he gave him a
weapon he's giv you a weapon yes yes
girl you be so grateful he saved your
lives I'm not enjoying these what she's
saying can't take you with me you'll
slow me down we won't slow you down so
you're really just going to leave us
here he gave you a weapon dude why did
you save us if you just going to leave
us here would die please help us wait I
I can get you a car yeah offer something
I I have a friend in the city not far if
you get us there safely you can take her
car and do what you have to do where she
live D and Bryan she's
smart make sure love
it love it this woman this girl better
say yes when she calls her I know right
y can my friend over your car you the
answer bettering be yes I I'll explain
when I get there okay what are you
looking for Sniper
right that guy in that roof remember she
lives with her parents they're happy to
have us if you can get us to her place
safely the car is yours can she help us
too you're useless yeah she really I
don't I I really I'm not trying to be a
[__] but she's useless she was like
you're giving us a gun to what I say you
stay close you slow me down I cut you
all loose yeah yeah yeah understood yes
sir Purge daddy why is he literally the
hottest man on the
Planet a
virus
oh control the masses nourish and flish
he's going to have to kill this guy I
think he's a woman I am a one
woman you're all in my PA oh my God
M9 silver TI Auto Magnum the right arm
of the Free World and the left hand of
God y [__] be crazy she's nuts I was
just trying to make out what the heck
she was saying and now I'm no thanks the
sound design on this every single
gunshot feels like it's hitting
me it's like all a jump scare and I also
like how a lot of the lighting they play
with it's all pink and blue which I
really it's draws my eyes in I love it
usually with the Shadows it's just that
gray black but they really do they have
some color Pops in here which really
nice we're going to cross Banks no no no
that's a long way it's going to be much
quicker if we go down here no don't do
that oh what was that oh my God it's a
trap what you're going to what going to
shoot it what
okay holy junk shoot the cable oh d d d
oh my God come on y'all he gave you a
gun help him out I can't believe how
useless Matt s and his partner are yeah
it's terrible he's telling you to shoot
it sh shoot a trap why are you guys not
shooting the Trap come on man shoot he's
saying shoot the
Trap okay you got it oh great now we
have all these people after us I I
honestly can't get over how moronic
those two are they really are I'm not
saying I would be better he's a littleit
he at least he at least shot the Trap
after like seven times I'm Liz and this
is a
shame AA my daughter C Li Shane Ava c
doing intros okay is anyone else kind of
curious about this guy I'm just glad
that he's out here with us yeah me too
but we all got stuck out here and he
chose to be that means he's purging dude
he saved your lives he told you he saved
Our Lives all I'm saying is that he's
out here armed to the teeth on purite
voluntarily means he's trying to do
something nasty I can hear you yeah he's
like right there you dumb
dumb he gave you one of his weapons you
idiot brought us out of the movie making
because it's just like you know in
movies where nobody can hear whispering
go hey step over here and they're 2 ft
away as if nobody can hear what they're
saying what's your name you're good with
guns I'm guessing you're either a cop or
a criminal and I'm guessing you're
either a pain in my ass or a pain in my
ass Callie you got to chill what are you
going to do stop you shut up all of you
shut up yeah I'm going to stop talking
because you're being an [__] okay not
because you told me to shut up you don't
bite the hand that feeds you in this
scenario come on like oh no oh no what's
the red light oh oh what that here hangs
stock broker David newat still on
pensions now he's gone wow I bet you
that would happen all over town yeah is
that tear gas smoke
canister we were just doing our duty oh
my God look at his uniform this is one
of the bastards who came into our
building they're just doing their Duty
yall need to start taking off their yeah
totally putting it on immediately yeah
but they're useless so they won't go
check the cab see if this thing's
working stay alert stay alert go ahead
go go all right Callie what are you
going to do that's awesome look at this
they're accessing the city's traffic
camps traffic camps are controlled by
the government how did they get into
these I mean who are these people maybe
you just answered your own question yep
government is that your building yeah
but why is it all red you're being
targeted for something along with all
these other buildings here here all over
the city huh maybe you're right cie look
I'm telling you this is the new founding
fathers the trucks no good no the
engine's all blown out or something okay
Shane delivering more bad news that's
Carmela's Mark mom I told Papa he was
the real deal his group took these
out oh no oh no God y'all should yeah
exactly grab a weapon and grab a vest oh
no oh God I hate it oh
god oh
boy oh my God I don't like it the knife
stab sound you guys going to take the
subway that would be awesome is it
working oh it's a rat do not say
anything you [__] yeah not oh my go
she's gonna
literally shut the up here we
go you at a restaurant that's
gross oh
nice loving this choke out right now cuz
they can't do guns or everybody will
come has nobody else had to kill
somebody else it's just you Frank goow I
correct cuz they well they had guns
right there earlier no nobody did
anything with them
so I kind of like their relationship
though Callie and Frank why'd you help
us we establish a no talking Rule people
are getting killed all over the city why
did you stop for us cie is me I can't
stop asking questions we were putting up
a hell of a fight he reminded me of
someone who his daughter that's what
broke him and his ex-wife up cuz she got
taken killing doesn't help anything it
doesn't heal someone enough enough go
back with your mommy he wasn't purging
yeah also he saved you I don't
understand the questioning because he
did save your life but he is armed to
the teeth so she is thinking he was out
to purge yeah she's saying no matter
what the reason's wrong but you don't
know that that's what he was doing right
Kelly sometimes we got to learn to zip
at us us talkative [__] yeah I mean
this guy he's a fortress he's not going
to tell you put this on I don't need
that put it on I said I said I don't
need it put it on yeah listen to H Jesus
yeah from here and out she just be yes
sir Purge daddy and nothing else I bet
that thing saves her
life what was
that oh no they're all
scared there's no threat they're just
trying to make it through the night oh
that's so sad hey you okay I just want
to get out of here she can't breathe
she's having a panic attack or something
I guess okay I'm going to need AA to
keep it
together oh no oh my God how they get
cars down
there oh I guess they can fit that down
the stairs and in through
the
W yeah this is a whole oh God this is
what
happens oh my God my God they run over
his body oh my
God is running really going to help no I
mean
oh my
God she can't get up and run honey even
if it hurts let's
go what's happening she cannot breathe
legitimately hard to watch she having a
panic attack he's going to carry her out
he doesn't have time Eva you got to pull
it together babe you're in a vehicle
we're not going to make it okay Shane do
something I then use your
gun somebody do something okay Shane
what are you doing my God we do just
shoot yeah just shoot just shoot
whatever your name is k
them yeah do something useful aim for
the head aim for the head head shot come
on now you got shot in the arm come on
now oh my God I'm F I'm F I'm F just
keep shooting yeah keep shooting yeah
just forget about him come on girl you
were going to leave him anyway yeah oh
exactly oh yeah get him get him come on
get a head shot
yes that is so satisfying yes okay all
right yes Redemption is yours redeemed
yourself you're bleeding I cut it on the
platform it's fine we'll help you just
tell us I said it's fine okay Frank he's
been shot I have no idea how
bad call your friend all right we're
close we're going to get him up Frank's
also bleeding but nobody yeah there are
4 hours and 30 minutes remaining in this
year's
Purge so how many hours are there 12 I
guess I don't
remember oh no oh great yeah we remember
the government's utilizing the cameras
yeah we have a Target match on the
civilians Who attack Truck 2 oh no oh
great Target
match whoa and they come in
semis yeah we saw oh right cuz it's a
gar I got it yeah this just looks bigger
from up above gr shot no oh no Talia let
us in Talia Talia let us in bro you guys
look like hell come on come on hurry up
girl we've been out during Purge Night
oh no she's going to end up dead for
helping it's going to be
[Music]
sad I can't believe you guys went
through all that stuff it's just insane
she's drinking wine and she looks like
she's just
relaxing come on everybody eat drink yes
I recommend drinking it's the best way
to get through the evening oh no but the
government's coming here right now yeah
they're about to break through what
about you tough guy want to drink no
thanks okay you're really going back out
there somewhere I have to be my father
and my brother-in-law he need a super
they were just checking the building
don't mind my husband's clothes he's not
purging he just thought it was a crazy
idea to go out and see what's happening
tonight wait I don't know what the hell
I was thinking thank God he came to his
senses I mean look at him he would have
been the laughing stock of the
neighborhood oh no is there some sneaky
business that's about to go down
building's locked down and good you had
a rough go over it my friend yeah relax
make yourself at home you're safe here
oh no anything else you need just ask I
could use a clean shirt down the hall
second door on the left top drawer of
the bureau what's mine is yours it's
very nice I feel like it's also an
excuse used to like look around I don't
know he must be going somewhere where he
needs to be in a clean shirt what is
your theory on where he's going I feel
like he needs to well maybe just might
just need a shirt but I'm also to take
care of his
wound yeah he's going to find something
right like it has
oh she knows that the government's
coming or something what's happening she
gave a weird look like she wants to
Purge or like I don't know she could
think of a couple
scenarios does it hurt as much as the
heartache scared the [__] out of me this
is their meute their second they're G to
fall back in love
[Laughter]
perh I don't know how that works always
on me sad actually it's my favorite I
think you do it for
me sorry I got a shot oh are you going
to use this excuse for the rest of our
life a let's change the atmosphere up in
here no more person I got peret in my
system and red wine I feel like it's
Xanax but
okay come on oh this sister she's not
going to like it why are you fluttering
with her husband your friend likes to
drink and she's taking pills back there
yeah she's pretty wild but we'll be okay
line do you care if we dance she doesn't
even care she ATT I don't know how to
thank you I hope they're in love you're
going out there to kill someone who
wronged you you believe in this Knight
don't you I think you should just take
care of your daughter and I need the car
make out say I love you before he goes
there is no
car she was trying to keep you safe but
we needed you and I needed the car I I
did what I had to I did it for my
daughter I was doing this for my son and
I trusted you I knew it you have no idea
what you might have taken away from for
me
tonight yikes please come on you're safe
here oh no oh no great here we go what's
Happening Here We Go yep oh my
God
holy she knows they're having an affair
so she killed them she's your sister
lorine what are you doing I read all
your emails you cheating mother you both
deserve to
die oh my
god get back get back back up back up
sorry okay I'm sorry oh oh so let us cut
this out you this is my right granted to
me by my government yeah
Frank
O oh whoa Frank shot the guy to make him
let go the girl yeah he's a g great
shot oh my God this crazy lady Frank
doesn't want to kill her he's like bum
that cheating now now you guys deal with
it you've got be [__] kidding me how
did they find them how did they find
them this movie is awesome dude yeah I
don't understand why it has like a 58%
rating the tension the music the scoring
the whole
thing he's here I know it and I want him
he's here okay so he wants Frank Gilla
he shot me shot half my team I want him
dead Exposition yeah I was like that's
the only part that is like oh we didn't
need that you can recognize who he is is
I want him dead move now we have 30
seconds move over the fence fast now
go yeah go go useless woman isn't
useless anymore however no she just
takes a little too long to do stuff
though oh no oh no oh no what oh just
knew
it oh he's in a truck yeah but he's not
taken by the government government he's
taken by these people the
purgers did they get AA and her people
too that's what I'm wondering do they
have all of them I'd rather be taken by
these people than the government people
oh yeah they have all they got all of
them okay why are they keeping them
alive yeah like where are they taking
him why aren't they just doing it right
there how did you find
us like do they work for the government
people right I I also am curious how did
they even know the the guy with the hat
know where they were how did they know
that they were even at that
building we got lucky we was roaming
around out there all night this is he's
W an Oscar why haven't you just killed
us already we're not purging tonight we
don't need to kill anyone just need
money they have money they have $100,000
yeah R me my money man let's go let's do
this what are they
doing oh wow did they just do that all
night capture people get
paid maybe this is where Frank wanted to
be anyway maybe there people who took
his kid if you move or speak you will be
shot
oh my
God oh my God this is so messed up just
every element dude and what they bid on
them I bet ladies and gentlemen since
this is the last Purge of the evening
the entry price will be2 200,000
wow it's like the puru dant ball I tried
to make it work to be like a debutant
ball it didn't work the head of
sists all right one spot left anyone
else they do this every year Mr
HST the music bro oh I mean it's just
everything is like perfect I hope one of
these people killed Frank grillo's kid
and he kills kills him so hard good luck
we'll see you shortly on the hunting
grounds come on what the this is just so
like it's not even out of the realm of
the possibility of in my brain I just go
yeah that would happen which is so sad
hunting grounds they're going to have to
run and fight it's like squid game but
with the
purge oh my
God are they like in a museum they have
to survive an hour right or whatever the
wow this is I mean oh my God it's like a
whole different movie all of a sudden
not in a bad way just like in like a it
just keeps one up against it's like hold
my beard no hold my beard no hold my
beard now have this
Martini really interesting choice to
have the people in The Masks be people
that were looking to just get money you
know I bet you they just go around
kidnap people they give them and they're
just like yeah I mean but that's why
it's from the top down like you know
yeah and we see oppressed people
oppressed people we can't see we're dead
we should come back you we need you to
stay just listen to him scar coming back
Callie this is when we zip yeah and we
let him lead [__] I like I've taught you
yes sir Purge daddy he's got to take one
of them down oh my God I am sorry this
is the wrong time for this he is so
sexy he is just truly so sexy to me in
this in this dim neon lighting as The
Purge Daddy yeah
oh see he knows hand to hand get that
weapon
nope oh yes nice nice did they see that
I think they did they look
shocked oh my God how is he going to
survive this he didn't get the gun no
but he needed to get the goggles to see
or something but he didn't I don't think
I don't know some John wickness did he
get the
goggles well now he got the go hey
baby get the other pair too see all the
rest of you never again yes now just go
pick off there boom boom bye yes ter
Boom Boom by as easy as Boom Boom
by whoa came in swinging yeah remember
they are good with their
blades shoot them didn't he have the the
gun did he drop it I don't
know D is she fit him probably most
people who get captured and brought in
here usually aren't good Fighters
because they got captured right though
they're not used to this whoa I think
you just
got he's just gaining all the glasses
the glasses and then he gives it to all
of them so
smart oh shoot through the window is it
bulletproof of course it is yeah you
[__]
that's what I'd be
yelling perch I almost just did it to
you God there's three left it's loaded
you point and you shoot why did he give
it to you so's
coming light them up I guess she did was
the one who took out the ones in the in
the yeah that was a good shot I think
she did
it oh they're leaving oh yeah you better
leave run run little doggies they're
going to bring no they're going to bring
gas in here or something
no get out of the room what was
that oh no uh here we go oh my God
that's so many people that's all right
Frank Frankie can handle them bro
there's like 40 of them I know but like
maybe he can John W get out I love you I
need you to know oh wow that was
wow
what a this is like such a powerful
movie do you think anybody's going to
make it out maybe cie cie has the vest
on did we forget that yeah cie does have
the vest on yeah she might be the only
one and and maybe Frank and cie because
he lost his son but he doesn't lose her
right she's the only one that I said was
going to die at the beginning now she
she might make it oh wait somebody come
to help them who who is this
oh is this this is the guy on the TV
right and then the gr's going to be like
we know you that's what he look like on
the TV but maybe wait that's the guy
from the first one oh that's the
military guy not fire we're here to help
you isn't
it yep yep
yep what that oh my
God too bad Matt Sison didn't make it
out who the are you nobody special just
some people who don't necessarily agree
with the pares all oh our guy yes See's
going to go John yep she knows the new
founding
fathers W you your money and mother The
Purge I love him ah you once said that
the mark of mentality will no longer
keep the American people stunted we are
outraged and we're fighting back nice to
meet you too young lady oh that's so
sweet oh my God he's very
emotional stay you
hey we got to go oh no he almost made it
I want to purge what look we'll take
care of her go we got it I'm sorry get
some weapons see if they have extra she
said I want to purge that see that's how
we create monsters get ready to bleed
rich [__] ass it's around time
there oh God no no don't shoot me don't
Sho she so wrong but I hope he kills her
you remember me yeah okay shoot her in
the leg in the foot now
run run run come on just a little shot
in the calf or
something no he won't cuz he's a good
guy that's fine all right
the owner of that house killed my son 12
months ago Nicholas was coming home from
school and he swerved off the road oh
blood alcohol level was three times the
legal limit but you know he got off on a
technicality so so it wasn't during The
Purge oh him and his wife and his two
little kids well they live in that house
happily ever after two weeks ago I came
here and I disabled his back barricade
that's what we're doing here I want you
both to stay in this car do you
understand me T immediately said no no
the thing is they make us feel
conflicted because they didn't kill him
in the purge they killed him because he
was drunk and that's still effing murder
yeah but it's you know that his
intention was not to murder somebody
right it was an accident but also it's
like
well there are you're cutting it
close no don't talk get up
no maybe he's not going to kill him I
don't think maybe he's going to like
tape him took my boy you took
my took my maybe it wasn't him maybe it
was her and he covered for her you're
going to pay for what you did to me what
you did to my boy she's going to do
something what the five minutes are
up whoa she killed him
anyway or is this a new person maybe he
didn't kill him oh my god wow I don't
think he killed him but of course this
guy don't save lives tonight we take
lives fortunately the citizens aren't
killing enough so we supplement it all
oh it's important work the nffa does and
we can't have any interference can't
have Heroes he's going to be able to
shoot him right cuz he do a gun I know
I'm thinking
what happen Blessed Be America nation
reborn somebody take him out yeah there
you go nice head
shot was it the guy he could cuz he
didn't kill
him oh no they're under direct orders to
take the girls alive if they see them
but I'm like do they actually follow the
rules they're going to kill this guy
Jesus
oh
you listen to that I think so because
there's cameras everywhere facial
recognition cuz I was like why would
they follow the rules now I yeah they're
outside yeah is he G to make it through
this I think he's going to survive he
got a car you got a car go get it out go
okay what about the car they came in oh
yeah is it dead or something three come
on they I mean it's good he got shot now
cuz the hospitals are open right
now do you think there would be no think
that other girl lived useless oh all
right she went yeah I think they
probably protected her and she was able
to I would love to go back and be like
who did she get to kill I guess is like
one of the rich
people is he going to make
it he's just going to grab her hand and
die don't say that
per
[Music]
there me a long line yeah right like I
might but they did get there just in
time like I was saying the hospital's
just open like five minutes ago they
shot him a couple times right
yes you think he lived yeah what
happened to the girl with the group do
we girl I think she live too care yeah
okay James
demonica Blum all right there we go my
God that kid that after the kid shooting
Micha Michael B this it have some
Michael B
yeah oh my
God
this H the the choice of this song to
play like during the and then the
disruption of it that's Frank gillow
Love You Frank Daddy Carmen hogo that
must be the girl
that Zach Guilford that's the dude's
name that was in Friday night Friday
night okay
yeah Don
know Zoe Soul Zoe Soul that's I think
she either was in the the last so we
know he was the dude from the last time
okay yeah Michael K Williams that's his
effing name dud that's the guy's name
and he did die recently right I think so
I gotta look
dang I can't believe I didn't pull that
I'm pretty sure let me well we can look
at it a different time you guys will
tell what's his name again Michael K
Williams that's his name I'll look it up
um whoa that was uh I I am shocked that
this had a significant dip and even the
people in the comments told us that the
first Purge is great he died September 6
2021 yeah sad he he's been in like every
major show that we've loved um yeah the
wire Bravo exactly um oh my God Keith
Stanfield who's that I don't know the
one that you
recognized the one that I recognize yeah
what's his when he when he said I'm just
doing for the
money oh that's his name I'm pretty
sure yeah really pretty sure oh weird I
mean he's great he was in an Oscar
winning fil look Keith
but maybe he just went by Keith I don't
know um that was wild w look what's
happening now it's just po oh it's just
for USA watch I thought that that was
still part of it we were just watching
water uh okay obviously we watched the
first one together now you've seen the
second one did you do you have a strong
preference um oh yeah good
um no I mean I really don't know why
this second one has gotten bad reviews I
mean it looked like when we looked at
the ratings like to click on it to like
58% and I'm like I like this movie I
thought it was good I thought the first
one was really really great in a way
different way and then them taking us on
the road in this one was I mean I found
it just not like the exciting is the
wrong word but I did think that it was
an exciting movie that kept me very
engaged because we got to see so many
different parts of the purge that like
we did not get to see in the first movie
of people moving around and what they're
doing and I really like the John Wick
like essence of what purge Daddy was
doing of like saving people but really
he was on a mission to kill the guy who
killed his son and he needed those
people that he ran into that he saved to
help him along the way like he went
through this journey all night of like
recognizing he he didn't really want to
purge him like I think he he needed
those people he needed them in in his
path to make the change which I really
like that story I like that plot line I
think it's good yeah I'm definitely with
you this this movie just felt a lot
bigger right the the first movie was so
contained and we're in this house and
you feel claustrophobic in the house
right like it's all about who H can come
in the house well the barriers of the
houseold um your neighbors you know the
people that you know can you trust the
people that you know um and what would
you do for a stranger this entire thing
was all strangers and we have the entire
world yeah and also kind of makes you
rank bad right like the guy that was the
drunk that breaks into their apartment
yeah because he's been so badly
oppressed he's now become an absolute
oppressor during The Purge right right
but that is something that is a learned
behavior from the rich people that are
killing people in the streets right um
who are not at risk in the same way you
know like just there's so many levels of
this movie because now we're seeing how
it permeates through entire soci the the
entire Society um the one thing that I I
like it's it's not a nitpick as much as
I am curious with a character like Frank
gillow who is out to for revenge for his
son's death right I don't know if I
realistically see him waiting for Purge
Night you know what I mean like I know
crime is down but I don't feel like the
reason he would do this is because now
there are no consequences I don't know
if he really gives a [__] about the
consequences you know right um but
whatever take that aside I guess he's
like I just have to wait a year because
when when he said it was 12 months 12
months ago I just assumed it was on that
Purge that Purge night and then he
wanted to do payback for that but it's
like it was 12 months ago and you waited
for the night that you wouldn't get in
trouble for it I don't think at that
point he cares I think at that point
we're seeing he doesn't have much to
live for left or he believes that
obviously does have a lot to live for
right but it didn't distract for me or
detract for me it more just was like huh
I wonder if there is going to be a
version of The Purge I mean right now
they started playing the TV show um we
know there are more movies like is there
ever going to be a version where we see
what the purge world is like on non
Purge days to see like how are people
interacting it with not with zero crime
apparently and how how does that like
and are the consequences so much worse
because there is Purge day so like if
you know you are caught shoplifting
during the year and not on Purge day are
you sentenced to death right are you
like hung or something or like
electrocuted like if you're starving and
you take a loaf of bread then are you
killed like because of what purge day
allows so I am curious now this movie
made me really curious about this entire
universe that they've built because we
saw more but still not everything uh and
also it unlike the first one which I
still loved but this one really tugged
at my heartstrings in a way that was
like because you're just watching when
he said nice to meet you too uh girl
like I I was like it it did kind of make
me emotional because they were both on
the same plane when Michael K Williams
character comes in I said to cie I was
like
I don't know it just felt like such a uh
like a moment of a of a figure for her
that represented it's not necessarily
good but it kind of is I mean he just
kind of
came they're there because they needed
to be there it's the resistance and it's
yeah like I think both you and I think
that that's problematic right but also
if you're not if that's what's happening
to you what are you supposed to do what
are you gonna do you might as well like
just go
the all of these rich dummies can't just
kill us all off like we have to fight
back yeah that was that was a great
moment the other great moment for me is
when Frank gillow does say we're not GNA
they're not going to let us out of here
yeah we got to make them earn it yeah
and and everybody kind of looks at him
and they're like okay yep um but also
you know the fact that the I'm a lover
of Love shipper ships the useless girl
who wasn't useless in the end but her
her and Shane I was invested in that
love story the mother daughter love
story I was invested in but there were
some ends that we didn't get tied up
like I'm devastated about the
grandfather Yeah you know what happens
there also with the money and that I
thought that was going to come into play
that now they had that money and that
maybe but ultimately like what good is
money when you don't have your family um
so that was a devastating thing and then
what ends up happening with useless girl
we didn't fully tie that up right no is
there a third one yeah definitely CU
everybody in the comments kept telling
us the third one's amazing really cuz
I'm like they brought the guy from the
first one back and it was like a big wow
when I recognized him so I'm like maybe
I mean if we got to see that the grandpa
still lived because that group actually
saved him and who also ended up saving
his daughter and his granddaughter
there's no way right I'm like I don't
know there's no way I know they they had
knives ready they were already doing
their Purge prayer I definitely
saved but I do think that I would just
tape myself up with C4 if I was doing
that I can't believe the thing with the
sisters too yeah like you shot your
sister for sleeping with your husband
your sister was sleeping with your
husband also like is that infidelity is
that legal in this universe like or can
you only cheat on the on Purge Night
like just so many questions that was
really really well done this the scoring
just was so intense too we talked a
little bit about the um the usage of
light in this yeah it's great really
really strong the pops of color
throughout this is like made it so
interesting to watch but it's not pops
of color that made it too distracting of
like why would they be running through
an Alleyway and like you would see two
closed garage doors behind them not
garage doors uh storefronts that are
closed down but they'd have like a
bright green with like a yellow and
they'd be lit up but it just gave
throughout it there was pops of color in
it which I just was not distracting also
made the shots really interesting I
really like that cinematic approach when
they choose like a color scheme of like
how are we going to agre the dialogue
wasn't cheesy when it could have been no
it was uh like you said in the beginning
um you were like oh I'm I feel like it's
really natural right you said that right
off the top because because I think in
movies like this it could be like what
are we going to do if they come through
that door like you know and instead of
kind of just fell The Testament into the
acting too they do get some unbelievable
actors in here um and it is shot so dark
sometimes it is difficult to recognize
people unless you're Frank gillo in
which you are Frank Daddy from jump um
but yeah I just I really like this
franchise it really makes you think it
could be trash and it's excellent for
some reason great yeah just the from the
premise to the execution I just can't
get over how they were able to make
these I'm I'm shocked with how much I
loved both of the movies especially
after seeing it had like a 50% on Rotten
Tomatoes for this what I'm like who are
these people yeah what did you guys want
from a Purge movie if not this I love
that the story lines combined you know
that's a big deal for me um I love how
everything kind of merged and felt
organic like it wasn't like it didn't
feel too like uh because it would have
if the guy the magga guy we keep we're
calling that but the America guy it
would have felt weird if he had just
like found him and knew but it's because
he was like Sarge I knew where you were
headed yeah right and that's why same
thing with when I was like oh is this
where Frank gillo meant to end up like
that would have been too much of a
coincidence probably if he he meant to
end up with all the rich people because
they had taken his son or something
right so it was better the way they did
it yeah I I this a good movie yeah a
good franchise still just going like
that one Exposition part which we both
were like yeah with the the America guy
in the back of the truck just going like
he killed my friends and my whole team
and now I'm here and those two girls to
take them alive he shot me and now I
want him dead but the other two women I
want them alive I'm going to take them
that was the only part that I was like
we didn't really need that I think was
he attempting to take them for the rich
people or he wanted to take them alive I
think he wanted no cuz he said for
myself I believe he said I want their
mine to kill them which I'm gross that
guy I'm so glad he died there's so many
moments
that when the bad people die the rich
people who are the bad people in this
movie when they die It Feels So
satisfying like when the I keep SW when
the group that goes in and they're like
time to die rich [__] or
something I and they all go in and kill
all those men in their suits Michael K
Williams people yeah I found it so
satisfying and I know it's bad I don't
want like but did I found it very
satisfying they Warriors they're not
civilians they are Warrior like the the
I'm talking about the rich people like
they are they've created a rich Army of
people who are murdering yeah so they
deserve to get to die like I would also
kill them I would be like you guys are
part of the very big problem but then
the people who are kidnapping and
delivering them also a huge problem but
they're attempting to survive they're
not doing it to purge they're doing it
to live and it's like that's still wrong
but a different degree of wrong cuz if
it wasn't if they weren't working for
them they would be bait they would be
taken somehow somebody else is going to
take the job right if I was them uh and
I was kidnapping people to bring to the
rich people I would find bad people I
would do my research for the whole year
and be like who's messed up bad who is
here and I'm going to kidnap those
people the bad people and take them in
cuz they they did some bad stuff you've
got your own Purge movie to write yeah
exactly it'd be like a mix of that jod
Foster movie where she just sits on the
subway but she knows that this guy used
to like he did bad stuff to people and
she takes them out and she just does
that with her life it's a great film you
guys are going to leave in the comments
be like it's this film great film it's
like a mixture of that that's what I
would do I'd be like I'm going to
research all the bad people I'm going to
kidnap you I'm going to get paid you did
some bad juice you look up like
everybody who is at the Insurrection
yeah where you just like find people who
have completely like trash views on
women and you're like okay I'm talking
about anybody who's hurt a friend or
like done something to women you all are
[__] like I am taking you kidnapp you
I'm going to hurt you a little bit first
like you people who got off after like
six months of baby you're mine now
that's the people I'd capture for the
Brock Turners of the world yeah I hear
you I think that that's a good idea but
also like I don't think that they're
able to really they're grabbing who they
can grab easy from the street right
although the the one thing is that they
did set up Matt saris and and uh useless
they set them up because remember they
bumped into them at the store so it was
like then set up the bad people that's
what I mean I'm like just like I I mean
if you know you're going to do that on
that night I would just be like we need
to do some research and find out where
these bad people live and then let's
just capture them right and call call it
a night let's get all the bad people
that Keith Stanfield but he goes by
Keith Stanfield or was it not well I'll
look at you guys will tell us in the
comments yeah they'll let us know um all
right well Purge Purge
Purge just gonna do that for every
reaction now any final Purge thoughts
anything else you want to purge I loved
it I don't know what these people are
talking about when they're like it's a
it's a dud it's a it's a great film I
liked everything about it the way it's
shot the lighting the music it's great
choices great acting I was never out of
it thinking this person I don't believe
him I believed all of them so we want to
watch the third one so make sure you
like comment subscribe can we get a post
ring that Bell does it only happen once
ring that
bell ring the bell purch all that good
stuff so that we can come back here
thank you guys for watching Purge
Anarchy and for being absolute Anarchist
with us
Purge bye
[Music]